the jogan experience the stuff is
landing or crashing around the world and
unexpected countries have had this
happen and that's why I picked that
because I thought that was a interesting
case and then of course the you know pop
P the 12 and the Vatican were involved
back channeling it through the OSS which
became the CIA later to FDR and that's
how the US knew something weird happened
in Italy during well right before World
War II but so this is 33 was the first
like
documented uh that is the earliest one I
can talk about yeah there something that
predates that might you could infer that
you could infer that yeah so this 331
you said was in Italy yeah magenta so
it's uh I'm bad at geography I think
that's like Lombardi region it's like
Northern Northwest Italy and what's the
story behind it so um basically it it it
looked like it crashed right it the
original shape most likely was like a
lenticular disc like craft you know with
like a two dinner plates where
lenticular mean so like two dinner
plates you know smooshed together right
the hump and there's like a you know
like a bubble on top classic classic
like like that like that okay but it
looks like when it hits the edges broke
off so it became this like Bell or
Acorn shaped thing um and there was
nothing in it it was like just an
artifact you know there was no
biological remnants if you will um so
it's so funny because the Italians were
so confused they actually called up the
Germans and they were like is this one
of Y vava like what the hell just
crashed in Northern Italy musolini um
and this is all publicly available
information because some Italian
researchers um found all these original
documents that some people were sitting
on for years in Italy uh you know they
put a gag gag order on the press Etc and
yeah melini asked the Germans to come
down and of course the Germans came down
and they were like uh that is not ours
but let's look at it together so that's
kind of uh perhaps a tertiary reason the
kind of aess powers got together I'm not
saying that's like the reason but I
think the Italians and the Germans were
so intrigued with what they found from
like an artifact perspective there was
at least some scientific and Military uh
collaboration during the or the details
of which I'm not I'm not sure of but I
know people that know that specific
event that are currently still Intel
officers within this program uh in
detail but yeah so was there witnesses
to the crash or some sort of an
understanding that something had crash
landed and then they discovered it yeah
I I forget the precise
Discovery uh I don't know if it was like
uh local police officers or local
farmers found in the field something
like that I I don't want to misspeak um
I assume some of the Italian researchers
might have some fact witnesses that can
orally say oh yeah my my
great-grandfather found it or something
like that but I don't remember I'm what
was the scale of this vehicle uh it was
probably like like 20 feet by 10t
something like that not super huge but
kind of big do they think that this was
a drone do they think that this was
occupied there was nothing in it so if
it if it was uh piloted if you will by
some sent I mean your your guess is as
good as mine so H so what happened to
that vehicle so we knew where it was
being stored at a a particular location
um after the crash and then the military
came in and we we grabbed it towards the
end of the war you know 1944 1945
because like I said pop Pi the 12th
already kind
of let uh FDR know why did the Pope get
involved because it's in Italy well
interestingly enough there's like a
whole history of human intelligence
prior to World War II and uh old money
the Vatican the Italian mob um kind of
the old country boys did a lot of
informal intelligence collection uh for
the US and and there's probably some
books you can read on it but it's really
interesting you know human intelligence
collection wasn't really formalized
until the office office of strategic
Services the OSS which became the CIA in
1947 and um you had um you know Paul
melon and all these other affluent guys
of all these old money families that
basically created the CIA so that's
probably the reason why so this thing
that was recovered this was the first
documented one that the United States
had access to I can't get into if it was
the first or not but okay it was an
early one very early yeah so it's almost
100 years ago yes and so so they take
this thing and then they bring it
where yeah I can't I can't get into
those can't get into okay so they bring
it somewhere in the United States and uh
was the attempt to try to back engineer
this thing was the attempt to try to
understand what it was yeah I mean first
of it obviously it's understanding the
situation right what do we have our
hands on and and like I've said in some
other videos and stuff you know that we
took the Manhattan Project secrecy and
overlaid it on this issue because that
secrecy worked well for atomic bomb
developments and whatnot and and
certainly this whole program in a
nutshell if I were to like summarize the
90 plus years of History it is a reverse
engineering program to Garner some kind
of insight uh and of course not a lot of
the things that we've learned from it
are like
directly you know ripped off the
technology we found but it has inspired
other innovations that made its way into
other us classified programs over the
year for National Defense reasons you
know and it's a myriad of different
things so the the UFO folklore is that
this is where fiber optics were
discovered first yeah I'm not going to
break the seal on anything we've
discovered or anything like that and
yeah it's place I can't go how limited
are you in what you can discuss and what
you can't discuss and why why do they
let you discuss any of this yeah so
anything sens that I want to say as it
relates to like US Government activity
whether it be intelligence stuff
military Stuff Etc I have to submit it
through what they call doser Dod office
of pre-publication and Security review
that is something anybody who's been an
Intel officer anybody with like a
clearance has to submit that kind of
stuff now obviously if you're writing a
book about gardening you don't have to
but if you're going to talk about
anything military and intelligence
related you have to submit so it's kind
of a catch 22 for this office right
they're only looking at it from a
security perspective they're not
vouching for it or anything like that
and that's like any author right they
could write a a book about Navy Seals
and they're not vouching for the story
they're vouching that you didn't say any
nasty code words you didn't burn a
specific ongoing classified program and
for them I mean I'm not in their udal
Loop but certainly it's a catch22 for
them where if they want to redact and
they propose a redaction they're like
Dave you can't say these sentences you
can rewrite it and resubmit you know we
can't necessarily tell you uh what
agency said to redact it but you're not
allowed to say
this uh they would be basically
self-certifying there's a there there so
in my opinion probably the policy is
like if it has to deal with the subject
we're not saying anything we're not
proposing any redactions as as long as
he's not burning a conventional
program uh we kind of have to allow him
to exercise his first amendment rights
and I so I think it's like a catch 22
for that office is kind of the long or
the short of the long answer so so this
is essentially one of the very early
ones 1933 MH how many crash
retrieval incidents have there been it
is double digit uh the specific numbers
I do know however I can't discuss that I
know it sounds like oh I'm being koi or
whatever but you know this show any
other interviews I do WR you know
foreign intelligence services are
watching and it's like I'm not here to
help Russia and China calibrate their
intelligence collection like oh Dave
said it's this number we missed a couple
[__] let's put it out for the KGB svr
and Gru are now going to hit the streets
to try to figure out which ones they
miss so I'm I'm here to protect National
Security and I'm just trying to put all
the general topics out there for public
convers ation to hold our government
accountable really so because I'm I'm
here as a fact witness because we have a
you know a constitutional oversight
issue because this
program has not
been you know reported to Congress in
the appropriate way you know and I can
get into a senator I talked to that has
died recently so I can you know explain
to you why I'm so sure besides what I
read which we can get into the what
Intel Port reports I read I did get some
stuff cleared um so during my
investigation I'm like you know what I
need to talk to somebody at the highest
levels right so and this will give you
an idea of the kind of people we talk to
and this is the only one I'm going to
talk about using their name because they
died two years ago so in Spring 2021 I
actually flew with a couple colleagues
of mine to Las Vegas and I met with
Senator Harry Reid
about nine months before he died and of
course he's a private citizen now and I
wanted to brief him
on the topic and I wanted to get his
kind of thought leadership on it because
you know he was a gang of eight member
right you know which is the top most
cleared senators in Congressman he was
the majority leader for God's sakes of
the Senate and I knew you know he helped
sponsor the assap program that I
mentioned and where they looked at
Skinwalker Ranch and some other things
and I wanted understand like what does
Harry Reid actually know like why did he
you know give $21 million to DIA in
Bigalow Aerospace for this so I'm
sitting there in Harry Reid's living
room you know right next to him with
some other witnesses that were there
with me and he straight up says he's
like yeah I knew we had UFO material I
was denied access for decades I tried to
get access and then he explains some of
his efforts during
assap uh and I was like holy [__] did
the the former Majority Leader just say
did he just confirm this to me as well
you know I was already talking to these
amazing highlevel people but I have
Harry Reid literally saying yes we have
material and you know he knew it was
non-human did Harry Reid have personal
experience with this I don't know if
he's had any personal stuff in his
personal life I mean did he see it did
he winess in terms of seeing the
material himself he said he was denied
access for years or decades was his term
and he actually told me on behalf of me
he was going so he had like a weekly
call with President Joe Biden at the
time and he straight up said to me he
was gonna talk to President Biden about
this issue
literally and then uh what he was
telling me about
assap um I was like holy [__] I have
like 20 other people that told me this
dude so the real history what [__]
assap was because I think there's a lot
of people out there that think they were
looking at ghosts Skinwalker Ranch yes
they went to the ranch as a secondary
inter tertiary objective but the
real uh reason so like there's a
document that came out a couple years
ago through Foya from the defense
intelligence agency there was this
special access Pro program requests that
Harry Reid you might have seen this I
think like George Napp and Company have
reported on this that he sent to the
deputy secretary defense William Lynn
and it was asking for one of the most
serious saps you can ask for what they
call a bigoted waved special Access
program so waved means it's limited
Congressional reporting um that is a
class of special access programs and
bigoted means it's like by name and it's
like it was like you could read the
foyet document it was like you know
Harry readed James inhoff uh Lando Etc
I'm like why are you asking for the most
serious sap to be created for a program
that ostensibly is looking at Skinwalker
Ranch and stuff and it doesn't make any
sense so what really happened there and
uh you know Harry mean Harry Reid God
bless his soul made this
disclosure um a couple weeks after we
met uh in the New Yorker and you can
look this up I think it was like a May
2021 New Yorker story where he says I
knew for decades and he made this
disclosure not me so I'm going to say
the name of the contractor Harry Reed
said this uh you know we knew that
lockie Martin had this material for
decades I tried to get access and I was
denied and specifically with the lockie
Martin stuff he was talking about during
the assap program and for the people who
are on this program I submitted this
[__] to officer got this cleared so
don't freak out but I'm telling the
truth here
um so lockie Martin wanted to divest
itself from this material at a specific
facility that's known to me that I
provided to the Inspector
General um like street address all that
[__] right and the idea was if they made
a catcher m a security catcher mitt for
this [__] at you know most serious sa
possible the contractor and the other
government customer which was the
Central Intelligence Agency um for that
specific locki material and it was [__]
that they recovered from like the 50s
and stuff and it was like bits and
pieces of of of of like Hall structure
[__] like that
and um uh so they were going to Tech
transfer it and the 21 or $22 million
was actually for Bigalow Aerospace to
build out you know facilities in Las
Vegas and material analysis equipment
and I've SE I have I saw the staff
meeting slides I saw the paperwork like
there's a paperwork Trail I've seen on
this [__] and I talk to the people
involved in this
program